monkey pox gets renamed so horny
primates won't feel ashamed
the World Health Organization has
announced that it would start calling
monkey pox mpox after hearing complaints
that monkey pox was racist and
stigmatizing it's not clear how many of
those complaints were serious or if they
were made by anyone hurling feces
laughs
who has a mandate to rename existing
diseases avoiding any association with a
country region animal or ethnic group so
I guess my idea the San Francisco smash
rash is out
[Laughter]
it's also it's also not clear how you
might accuse another person of racism
for using the term monkey pox
sure experts say that monkey pox is
mostly found throughout Africa until
recently but it was called monkey pox
not Africa pox and you can't associate
the term monkey pox with racism unless
you yourself are already associating the
word monkey with Africa but still it's a
relief to all the unfairly maligned Apes
out there
first we make them dress up in little
suits and bow ties then we name an STD
after them
it's also weird that who was worried
about associating diseases with an
animal after covering up the lab Leak
with bats now people freak out when I
eat bats I have to cut down my bat
eating
let's see what our expert has to say
uh yes doctor so the m in M pox totally
stands for monkey though right
so mpox is deadlier than monkey pox
great yeah we'll just keep calling it
monkey pox then yeah
oh so can Mbox
be transmitted if a monkey bites you
during sex
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
um science isn't about feelings with
with the phrase monkey pox the bad part
of the phrase is pox not monkey any kind
of pox is gonna be bad whether it's
monkey pox or Empire
or porn pox
[Laughter]
yeah this is obviously useless and makes
no difference but who doing things that
make no difference is actually a step up
from home what they were doing for
several years which is making a big
difference in a very bad way yeah and
you know what kills me uh Charlie is
that they actually might have a point if
they said people aren't taking it
seriously yeah because it's got a funny
name hence we do this because of the
name and now it's even funnier that they
call it m pox so they actually made it
funnier
yeah uh and not you but you didn't
um
no
but
the degree
[Laughter]
the degree to which these people who
claim to care about public health have
destroyed their ability or any
government agency's ability or the who
anybody's ability to handle Public
Health in any serious way they've
completely but clowned themselves by
being more concerned about the name of
something than I don't know a disease
that could actually kill somebody yeah
you know it's interesting I wasn't
listening
Emily
when we were kids I mean it didn't
bother it didn't bother us about
chickenpox in fact I think the armor hot
dog song armor hot dogs even kids with
chickenpox it wasn't like we're making
fun of kids because they look so gross
it was because it was because they look
gross I mean again
that elected officials and people in
decision making powerful positions are
spending their time on yeah what a joke
you know how much money we funnel into
the wa ho you know how much research and
stuff that we that we fund and that's
what they're doing I feel like mpox
reminds me of like remember that song
yep that's gonna mean everyone says from
now on and also
um
Hanson went stood behind me when I was
in a bathroom really yes did you talk to
him no which one wasn't there three it
was just a regular bathroom oh why would
that matter no I remember
it that that it's also like the artist
formerly known as Prince it doesn't
matter what you try to change the name
to because everyone's gonna still call
it lucky box or M pox you know monkey
pox exactly all right enough from you
longer Tyrus this is an example of what
you talk about external internal
problems uh they address an external
issue the name but has no effect on the
real issue the disease well obviously
two of the racist guys at work got
caught talking about monkey pox yeah and
then offered to save their son who
shouldn't have been in the building in
the first place they they changed the
name but yeah for some reason chickenpox
still runs rampant yes because there's
no way you could have filmed chickens
like skinny crackhead white people
what no one know what a chicken head was
I mean that's unfair to change that to
Sea pox yeah sea pox they have
chickenpox parties did you know that
Emily no but I still have scars from
chickenpox oh good for you
that's a weird little brag I guess
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else